Oh, reverse psychology. I like it.
Nice.
Three third. That's the first day we can
I can
Do you remember this?
Oh.
Yeah.
correlations
Okay, folks, time to get started. Um
I don't think you need reminders anymore
because we're at the tail end of the
class. 10 days left in the class.
And your project obviously is due on May
5th, and the numbers are due by May 4th,
so
you're almost there. If you've done your
DCF, it's getting the pricing done.
So, expect me to keep nagging you about
that because today we're also going to
start talking about the third aspect of
evaluation, which a few of you might
face. We'll talk about why it's only a
few of you where a real options might
help you understand what to do with your
company.
But I want to start today's session with
a very simple question. It's kind of
question that cuts to the heart of
thinking about something as a real
option.
Let's say you're a company that's
developed a new AI technology. What is
it going to do? It speeds up the
processing, reduces the cost,
but the technology right now is not
viable. What does that mean? If I
develop the technology today, the cost
of developing the technology will be 2
billion, and the present value of the
cash flows will be only a billion and a
half. Net present value is minus a half
a billion.
Let's start with the obvious question.
Should you implement the technology now?
It's minus a half a billion, bad net
present value, right? Technology is not
viable.
But could you see somebody looking at
this technology, a meta, an Apple,
somebody's interested in being in the AI
space, and saying, you know what, it's
non-viable technology, but it's it's
protected, it's patented. Would you as a
company be willing to buy a non-viable
technology?
And if so,
explain to me without using option
language
what it is that you're paying for.
You see what I'm saying, right?
Technology is not viable. I have the
exclusive rights to it for the next 10
years. Why might you pay for it?
Go ahead, Mary.
Exclusive access.
But to a bad project. What What's the
advantage of having exclusive access to
a bad project?
Go ahead, Mary.
Alternative applications. I'm sorry?
Alternative application of that. Right
now, let's say they're not there yet.
So, I'm I'm going to cut off all the
easy escape hatches.
Go ahead, Matt.
The opportunity to make more money.
That's always there, right? But right
now it looks like you lose money if you
take this project rather than make
money.
Michael.
Maybe
in the future, um
companies might want to use that like a
good solution. So, maybe they're not
there now, but Okay. What are the two
things that go into net present value?
One is how much it cost me to develop
the technology, and the second is the
cash flows I get. That's what I know
right now.
Right now, it doesn't look good.
I have the rights for the next 10 years,
right? A year from now I return to this
exact same project, and I project out
the cash flows, and look at the cost.
Could the Could the cost change?
Could the cash flows change? Absolutely.
You're buying this technology not
because it's viable today, but because
it could become viable, and here's where
having that patent
If this was just a bad technology, and
you didn't have exclusive rights to it,
I'm not paying for it.
But to the extent that you get exclusive
rights, I'm paying for it because things
can change. Remember we talked about
risk being your ally?
That's where it plays out. Uncertainty
becomes your ally rather than the enemy
because that's what's going to bail you
out.
So, let's build on this theme.
Let's think about what the value you'd
pay would be as a function of how long
you have left on the patent life.
It's an easy one. As the patent life
goes up, should the value that you pay
become higher or lower?
Higher. It should become higher. Giving
Having the right for the next 15 years
increases the chance that something good
will happen.
And the more uncertain you feel about
the future,
the more you're willing to pay, right?
See how odd that feels after beating up
on risk all this time, finally
So,
the less you know about a business, the
more uncertain you feel about it, the
greater the optionality becomes in the
business.
I've been through four big revolutionary
changes in my lifetime.
The PC business started, huge amount of
uncertainty, lots of
By the time you got to 7, 8, 9 years in,
the optionality had depleted.
The dot-com, the internet business took
off in the '90s.
At the start, nobody knew where this was
going. They just knew it was going to be
big.
Lots of optionality early on. As it
aged, the optionality kind of
dissipated.
Smartphones early on. Nobody had any
idea how big they would get, what they
would change. Huge amount of
optionality, it depletes over time.
Right now,
we're in that early stage of the AI
business. What are people talking about?
How big the market is. Nobody's giving
specifics. There's a lot of optionality
out there. People are paying for
options. They're paying for out of the
money options.
And most of the time, what happens when
you buy out of the money options?
They're going to end up not exercised.
That's the nature of this business. And
you have to make 50 different bets for
two to pay off, but if the two that pay
off are big enough, they cover the other
48.
That's at the heart of thinking of
something as an option.
So, I'm going to go back to the lecture
notes and and and
kind of complete that discussion we
started about
option pricing models.
And if you remember, we talked about the
two building blocks for the option
pricing models. So, Tolu, help me out.
What are the two building blocks for all
option pricing models?
How do we come up?
You can pass it on to Diksha. She She
think Is she I think she knows the
answer.
What are the two building blocks? Um I
think the payoff in the end and the time
period for the One is replication, that
you can create something that looks
exactly like the option in terms of cash
flows. And once you create something
that looks exactly like the option in
terms of cash flows, the second piece
comes into play, which is arbitrage.
Which is the two have to trade. That's
at the heart of all option pricing. You
saw that with the binomial, right? I
tried to create a combination of the
underlying stock and borrowing and
lending to get to the same cash flows as
the option.
And when I was done, I could tell you
this is what that replicating portfolio
will cost me, and by definition, that
has to be the value of the option.
Binomials are nice ways of illustrating
the process, but they're impractical.
Impractical, why? Because even if you
have a 3-month option, talk about all
those little branches,
you can't draw a binomial tree.
But you can make an approximation.
Which is, if the price changes get
really small as time becomes small, it's
called the continuous price
distribution, the binomial distribution
becomes the normal distribution.
And the binomial option pricing model
becomes the Black-Scholes model.
You're not allowed to graduate with an
MBA without having an intuitive
understanding of the Black-Scholes
model.
I'm not sure how intuitive it is right
now. Let's check it out, right?
First, do know the history of the model,
right?
Fisher Black and Myron Scholes were
professors at the University of Chicago.
They got this this the you know
essentially a brainwave. We can value
options by valuing So
I'm until 1971, people tried to value
options directly as if it was another
security. So they don't you know I think
Paul Samuelson came up with this you
know probabilistic model to value
options. And Fisher Black and Myron
Scholes the big insight they had was
rather than value the option, we'll
value the replicating portfolio.
But they didn't have the binomial. They
approached it
with a process that required what's
called stochastic calculus. So they got
stuck. Legend has it that they got stuck
writing the paper. They got to that
equation. They couldn't solve it because
nobody in finance had ever done
stochastic calculus.
And the legend also has it that a PhD
student in physics was walking by their
office what is it we see that all the
time. We use Ito's Lemma. Take no idea
what Ito's Lemma was, but it turned out
to be the magic that solved that
equation.
And hence was born the Black-Scholes
model.
Fisher Black and Myron Scholes won a
Nobel Prize for the model. The unknown
physics PhD student did not.
But maybe he deserves a piece.
So the original Black-Scholes model was
designed to value
dividend protected
options. You say what's a dividend
protected option? Remember what we said
that happens on the ex-dividend day. You
have a $50 stock price, the dividend of
a dollar is paid, the stock price tends
to go towards 49. With a dividend
protected option, your exercise price is
also lowered by the dividend.
Are there any dividend protected options
that work? Not that I know of.
But Fisher Black and Myron Scholes had
so much trouble deriving the model they
said we're just going to take dividends
out of the process.
So in the Black-Scholes, the value of an
option is a function of five variables.
S which is the value of the underlying K
which is the strike price, R which is
the risk-less rate, T which is the life
of the option, and sigma or standard
deviation reflecting the uncertainty it
felt about the stock price.
Five. The sixth variable of course is
dividends they assumed it away.
At the end of the paper with the help of
Ito's Lemma, they end up end up with an
equation. This is the Fisher This is the
Black-Scholes option pricing model.
How many of you use the exponential
button in your calculator?
Or the natural You you do
It's unusual, right? Most people don't.
Exponential, log-normal.
Black-Scholes makes you use all what I
call all those virgin buttons on your
calculator, right? Buttons you've never
touched before, right?
There it is all there in one place. And
nothing else would make you use all of
those equations.
You look at that equation and what the
heck is it telling me? Take a step back.
What did we do in the binomial model?
We solved for how much you need to
borrow B and how many shares of stock
you need to buy, right?
It's in the Black-Scholes model.
If you look at the model, it says S
which is the current stock price N of
D1.
Saying what the heck is N of D1? D1 and
D2 come from all those inputs in the
model S, K, R, T, and sigma. So you
first calculate that, then you go to a
normal distribution
and you look at the area under the
distribution to the left of D1. So
basically it's an area. Usually when you
look at distribution, they give you the
height of the distribution. This is the
area of the distribution. You're still
saying what the heck does it even tell
me?
That distribution is normalized because
the lowest number you can get is zero,
the highest number you can get is one.
It's like a probability.
The best way to think of N of D1 and N
of D2 is they give you a measure of the
likelihood that your option will end up
in the money.
The highest is of course is 100% one,
the lowest is zero, and the actual
number between the two.
So if you look at the model, it says S
times N of D1 an area under the
distribution.
Minus K E minus RT. E minus RT is just a
present value factor. Why? Because you
don't exercise the option till So if you
don't have an exponential button in your
calculator, just use the present value
function. Take the present value of the
strike price, it'll work pretty well.
times N of D2.
That is my replicating portfolio. N of
D1 is the number of shares of the
underlying stock I have to buy. So just
as in the binomial, we solved for that
delta, N of D1 is the equivalent of the
delta.
The K E minus RT times N of D2 is the
amount of money that I will have to
borrow
to fund that delta.
The replicating portfolio is embedded in
the Black-Scholes model.
So when you look at Black-Scholes model,
you're getting a number for your call
option, you're also getting the
replicating portfolio. The reason that's
so significant is one of your jobs if
you have a big option portfolio is to
hedge the risk in your options. Knowing
what that N of D1
That N of D1 in option pricing language
is called the option delta.
As the standard deviation changes, that
delta will change.
It's called the option gamma.
As the life to the option changes,
the op- the delta will change. That's
called the option theta. I do I mean
essentially option traders have taken
over the Greek language.
And everything to do So everything in
option pricing is around this
replicating portfolio and how it changes
as the stock price changes, as the
standard deviation changes, effectively
you need to know what the replicating
portfolio will look like to be able to
hedge the option.
That is the standard Black-Scholes model
for a non-dividend paying stock or for a
stock that is dividend protected.
So when you use the model, you're
effectively doing what you did in the
binomial, it just is easier because
you've let the standard deviation stand
in for all those little branches
and tell you how big the distribution is
and drives the value. So this this table
that you see here, if you have an option
pricing model in any way funds, I will
give you the table because getting a
cumulative normal distribution on your
on your calculator is kind of tough to
get. You can do it with Excel, but it's
tough to do on a calculator. So I'll
give you the table. You just look at the
D1, go across, and look at the N of D.
That becomes the N of D1 and the N of
D2.
So when you look at that N of D1 and N
of D2, they're probabilities and those
probabilities have a significance that
we're going to draw on. N of D2 is the
risk-neutral probability that your
option will end up in the money that S
will be greater than K. For the moment,
just file that away.
So when you do the option pricing model,
that N of D2 that's it's a prob- N of D1
is also a probability, but it doesn't
have the same kind of heft as N of D2
does.
So that Black-Scholes model, each piece
carries a message for you, not just the
end value.
Now one of the problems that you run
into with the Black-Scholes is
you know, that traditional Black-Scholes
model is without dividends. In the real
world, we do have dividends and in the
real world, our options are not
protected for dividends.
So there's a variant of this the
Black-Scholes model that's been
developed to deal with dividends.
And the way you bring it into the model
is through a dividend yield.
Remember the replicating portfolio you
went out and borrowed money and you
bought the stock, right?
So the borrowing that you borrowed at
the risk-free rate captures the rate at
which you borrow it.
You bought the stock.
What do you get in the stock?
You get dividends.
So if if you borrow money at 5% and your
dividend yield is 3%, while you're
having to pay out 5%, you can use the 3%
dividend yield to cover the 5%. It's
like a carrying cost.
So what you will see in the model is
that Y enters into the process in two
places. One is rather than use the
current stock price, you take the
present value of that stock price with
the dividend decreases. So that E minus
YT just taken to account the fact that
if you have a 3% dividend yield, your
stock price will drop drop by roughly
3%.
The rest of the equation basically
captures the fact that you have a
carrying cost that's lower now because
you have dividends in the stock.
That's the version of the model that
we're going to end up using in a lot of
real options because in many real
options,
while there might be no explicit
dividends, you have an equivalent of
dividends. Talk about why dividends
affect option pricing. You said that as
you approach the ex-dividend day,
there's a big dividend that day, the
stock price will drop, right?
And in fact with listed options, there
are about 5% listed options that get
exercised early. The biggest reason why
call options get why options get
exercised early is as you approach an
ex-dividend day, sometimes
the time premium on the option is less
than what you would lose if you waited
the extra day. So what you might get,
especially if you have a month or month
and a half, you're getting pretty close
to the expiration, you might see early
exercise on listed options just ahead
of an ex-dividend day. Yes. And also
sometimes you see
exercise early like with illiquidity of
like market.
That's with employee options, right? So
let's take that out of the process
because there the reason you're
exercising is you can't sell the option.
And here you're exercising in spite of
the fact that you can sell the option
because what you will lose by waiting
that extra day is less than what you
lose by exercising the option early, the
time premium. It's rare. The dividend
has to be larger.
Saying why would this matter with real
options?
We're going to talk about patents as
options. Typically when you get a
patent, you get the the exclusive right
to develop something for the next 17,
18, 19 years. Let's say it's 17 years.
If we treat this as an option, options
usually don't get exercised early. What
will happen? You wait for 16 years and
364 days
and then develop the patent on the last
day of which makes no sense at all,
right?
So, what the cost of what the dividend
yield does it allows you to introduce a
cost of delay, which is once the patent
becomes viable, I light a fire under
you.
Part of you wants to wait
cuz it could be worth money.
But, part of you also recognize if you
wait a year, you're going to give up
something, one less year of protection.
That becomes analogous to the dividend
yield. So, when you see us use this
model in real options, the dividend
yield becomes your way of putting
pressure on people to exercise an option
early because with the real options, you
want early exercise. You want patents to
be developed. You want oil reserves to
be extracted from the ground.
And that cost of delay is going to play
the role of pushing that. Yes.
The competition also
That could also cause it, right? So, in
a sense, you that acts like a cost of
delay by reducing the number of years of
protection. So, that just makes it even
worse. The cost of delay becomes even
larger.
So, what do you see as the Y in that
dividend yield adjusted version of
Black-Scholes will become the cost of
delay you got to factor in in real
options.
One final point, you know, when you look
at these option pricing models, the
Black-Scholes model
was developed first. It was developed to
value European option, which means it
was developed to value option that are
exercised only at expiration.
And if you are a real options purist,
you can already see the problem, right?
Cuz with real options, we said you want
early exercise.
So, there are purists argue you
shouldn't use the Black-Scholes because
it doesn't allow for early exercise.
Technically, they're right.
You could use a binomial, but the
version of binomial you use is going to
be such a
approximate version, I don't think you
gain much. I think you're better off
using the Black-Scholes with the
dividend yield as a lower bound cuz
remember, you can always use the
Black-Scholes to vary value an American
option.
You'll get a lower bound on the value
because you're not allowing for early
exercise. I'm okay with that.
So, I'm going to use the Black-Scholes
in spite of the fact that it's designed
for European options to value real
options where early exercise
can happen and often does happen.
One final point, um
there's an argument that you don't even
need option pricing technology to deal
with this.
If you do a full decision tree,
you can factor in all of the things you
bring into real options without ever
bringing up Black-Scholes or binomial
models.
You've seen decision trees, right? You
start at the each branch you start with
a node. This is for example, a decision
tree for a pharmaceutical company with a
single drug working its way through the
pipeline. So, there's your starting
point, test or abandon. At each stage, I
put the probabilities and the expected
outcomes.
Wait. And when you when you use a full
decision tree, the way you value the
decision tree is you roll it back. So,
it's an expected value to each stage.
You do the right thing. You can actually
get the same value you'd get with an
option pricing model using a full
decision tree.
Pharma companies, for companies where
you have the sequential risk,
I would suggest actually using a
decision tree rather than options
because why bring out, you know,
a blowtorch
when a matchstick can do? I mean,
basically, option pricing model, you're
bringing out all this heavy
equipment out when you really don't need
it with a decision tree.
So, that's a lead-in. Here's what we're
going to do. I'm going to introduce a
bunch of real options. I'm going to
start by first arguing why they're
options, showing the payoff diagram.
Then I'm going to make an argument for
exclusivity because without exclusivity,
there is no value. And then the third
test I'm going to run is is this the
kind of real option where I can use an
option pricing model to actually value
the real option.
Let's go back to what I started the
session with. Talked about traditional
capital budgeting, how in the process
we're ignoring these options, the option
to delay, the option to expand, the
option to abandon.
So, I'm going to start with the option
to delay
and use it to talk about why patents and
natural resource options natural
resource reserves can be viewed as
options. Then I'll move to the option to
expect,
which is what we talk when people talk
about strategic reasons.
What they're really talking about is the
option to expand. There are things you
might be able to do if you do this first
thing even though it's not going to make
economic sense.
And then we'll talk about the option to
abandon.
So, first step, the option to delay.
Let's set the table.
The option delay is usually about a
project where you have exclusive rights.
The cost of investing in the project
becomes the equivalent of the strike
price. The project itself is the
underlying asset. And the contingency is
the present value of the cash flows from
the project exceed the cost of taking
the project, you will take the project.
That might not be true right now,
but it might be true in the future.
So, if I were to draw this as a payoff
diagram,
the project becomes the underlying
asset. There's the initial investment I
would need to take the project. I will
take the project if the present value of
the cash flows exceed that initial
investment.
But, of course, that might never happen,
in which case what have I lost?
Whatever that negative, whatever I paid
to get the rights to this project.
That's a framework I'm going to use to
look at patents and natural resource
options, right?
So, let's start with valuing the product
patent as an option.
So, what does a product patent give you?
It gives you the exclusive right to do
something.
In the US, there are all kinds of things
you can patent. And you get the
exclusive right to do that for the next
17 years, 18 years, 20 years.
During that period, let's assume that
the cost of developing the product is I
and V is the present value of the cash
flows if you develop it.
So, I is what you have to invest to to
develop it. V is the present value of
the cash flows. If I were to write it as
a pair in terms of payoff, if V is
greater than I, I will develop this
project, keep the difference, develop
the patent, keep the difference. If V is
less than I, I throw the patent away and
say I wish I hadn't done that.
That looks like S and K in a call
option, right? And if I were to write
draw this as a
in terms of a payoff diagram, the cost
of converting the patent into a product
becomes the equivalent of the strike
price. The present value of the cash
flows I will get from the product
becomes the equivalent of the S in the
model.
And what I had to spend to get the
patent becomes the cost of the option.
How do you How do companies get patents?
What are the two pathways to getting
patents?
Yes. R&D or One is R&D. So, you can
actually think of R&D as the money a
pharmaceutical company spend to buy
options.
The other is you can buy the patent, in
which case that becomes the cost. So,
that becomes the equivalent of what you
pay for the option.
It's actually a very interesting
you know, case of real options.
It's probably the real option
application where I've lost faith the
most in it being able to work as an
option. I didn't know I'd talk about
why.
But, I can structure it. I can I can
talk about how it is. And as I structure
you're going to see some of the
weaknesses in making the real options
argument.
I'm going to actually go back in time to
to kind of show my example because and
you're going to see why because
much of the data that I need to value a
patent as a real option is private data.
The company has it, but nobody else
does.
With every one of my real options, I'm
going to take the real option and talk
about in the real world how I would try
to get the inputs for that real option.
So, let's take a patent, right?
You have a patent. You have X years left
in the patent. I want you to value it as
a as an option.
Here's the first thing you need to do.
You need to tell me what the present
value of the cash flows would be if you
develop the patent today.
I know it's not viable, but go ahead and
give me a number.
What will that require? It will require
traditional capital budgeting analysis,
right? It's 15 years of cash flows if I
develop it, these are the expected cash
flows. Here's my cost of capital, take
the present value, going to come up with
a present value of cash flows. Don't
subtract out the initial investment yet.
So, this is the present value of cash
flows. That will become the S in the
model.
The strike price is you developing the
patent. So, the initial investment you
will need to get these cash flows will
become the K in the model.
But, here's a key input. That S you get
the present value of the cash flows is
what you get as a present value today.
It could change over time.
That becomes the variance you use in the
model is how much Your response will be,
"How do I know what that variance is?"
For those of you who were in my
corporate finance class, one of the
things we did in capital budgeting is in
addition to computing a present value of
the cash flows, we also did Monte Carlo
simulations.
I think it was the Disney theme park, we
know we did.
And what do you get out of Monte Carlo
simulation? You not only get a net
present value, you also get a standard
deviation of the present values from all
of the different scenarios.
So, one way to get that standard
deviation is to look to run a
simulation, take the variance across the
outcomes.
But, that's a lot of work. So, I'll give
you a lazier way of doing it.
You're a biotech company.
You got a new new you got a patent.
I can look at the publicly traded
biotech companies in space, take the
standard deviation in stock prices and
argue that that's not a standard
deviation reflects the uncertainty in
the business. It's a bit of a reach.
And use that as my standard deviation in
the option.
So you can either run a simulation, get
a standard deviation specific to this
patent
or look at publicly traded companies and
take the standard deviation stock
prices.
The expiration of the option, when does
the option expire?
Whenever your patent expires. So we have
15 years left in the patent, that
becomes the T in the
The riskless rate basically matches up
to whatever the life. So I'd go look up
a 15-year treasury rate of a 15-year
life. I've got all of the inputs.
So I'm going to take you back to 1997
or 1998, a company called Biogen.
At that time, the second largest biotech
company in the world, but still a very
small company.
They developed a drug called Avonex.
And they patented it and they had 17
years left on the patent. And now you
can see why pharma companies wait as
long as they can before they actually
patent because the clock starts running
the minute you patent.
So you got 17 years left in the patent.
It's a drug to treat MS.
And in this case, I actually got my
hands on an internal company document
that projected out the cash flows from
developing the drug.
For those of you who have never seen
these documents, it's actually a both a
morbid and a scary document cuz here's
what it starts with. It starts with a
percentage of people it was designed to
be drug for the US, percentage of people
in the US who have MS.
And then it takes a percentage of those
people who will go to a doctor, which is
not 100%.
And they'll give you the percentage of
people who go to a doctor who get the
right diagnosis and that's not 100%
either.
And then they don't get the percentage
of people who get diagnosed who can
actually afford the treatment, which is
definitely not 100%. So you might start
with 15 million people having this
disease and by the time you're done,
your market is down to 2 and 1/2 million
people.
And then you put then you have to
estimate a price you can charge for the
drug, which requires you kind of gauge
how much insurance companies will pay,
Medicare will pay, and then you build
out the cash flows.
They done the analysis and come up with
the present value of the cash flows if
they develop the drug today of 3.422
billion dollars.
So they did my dirty work for me.
They've got the S.
They also estimated cost them 2.875
billion to actually develop the drug.
To give you some background, the way
a drug gets developed in the US is you
got to develop a huge sales force to get
it out to the doctors. And Biogen had
never ever developed any of their drugs
on their own. They had two other drugs
that had been patented, but they had
licensed them out to traditional bio
pharmaceutical companies. So this one
they planned to do on their own, cost
them a lot of money, 2.875 billion. Let
me pause right there. Present value the
cash flows is 3,422 million.
The cost, the initial investment is
2,875 million. And if this were
capital budgeting, I would stop right
there and that difference
is 547 million is the net present value
of the project. File that away
cuz that is the discounted cash flow
value of the project, net present value.
But they haven't developed the drug yet.
They have 17 years left on the patent.
And for the standard deviation, I'm
going to cheat and use the average
standard deviation of publicly traded
biotech companies to get that.
I could have tried a simulation, but I
don't know enough about this business to
even put in the distributions. I'm going
to assume that that's going to capture
the uncertainty about the cash flows.
And finally,
is this a viable drug already?
Net present value is positive, right?
3,422 is higher than 2,875.
It is viable.
They could develop it now,
but waiting a year might allow them to
come up with a better drug, have fewer
side effects. So you're tempted to wait.
But if you wait, what do you lose? You
lose one out of the 17 years of
protection
that you have.
I'm going to make that my cost of delay.
You're going to see me try this on every
real option because if I don't put in a
cost of delay, you know what's going to
happen?
Is Biogen will never develop the drug
until the last day of the 17th year. And
God help you if you have MS, you'll
never see this drug
in your lifetime.
So that becomes the cost of delay. I've
read the inputs that I would need for a
Black-Scholes. I'm going to plug them in
to a Black-Scholes model, which is
pretty mechanical, but I want you to
read the output fully, not just the end
value. So let's start out with the end
value, 907 million.
What the heck is that?
What is my NPV?
547 million, right?
When I treat it as an option, it's worth
907 million. Why? Because waiting can
give me benefits here and I'm capturing
that with a $360 million premium.
That basic that number becomes the real
option value of this patent.
And if you have MS, this is really bad
news.
Why?
Because if I develop the drug now, value
is 547 million. If I leave it
undeveloped, it's worth 907 million.
It's not quite hopeless because when I
do this again next year, assuming I have
the same cash flows, at least one number
is going to change, right? What's my
cost of delay going to be next year?
It's going to be 1 over 16, then 1 over
15. Each year the cost of delay is
rising.
In addition, the present value of my
cash flows will also shift. And in fact,
I looked to see the break-even point. At
what point in time the value of the
option will drop below the exercise and
it happens with
No, what about
12 years left in the patent, about 5
years.
The bottom line is when you have a drug
company develop a drug, there is going
to be this tension between should we
develop right now and and it's a viable
drug or should we wait and see if we can
make the drug better, have
And here's where I think there might be
something that we're missing because
this drug got developed almost
instantaneously.
And when I've tracked real options in
the pharma business,
pharma companies don't seem to wait like
you would expect them to when you have
options.
And Adil, I think gave a reason why this
might be happening.
How many years of protection do I think
I have?
17 years, right?
And Adil, fill in the detail. Do I
really have 17 years of protection?
I have 17 years of protection on my
version of the MS drug. I'm not given
protection against any version of the MS
drug. So if there are three other pharma
companies working on their own versions
of the MS drug,
I might have only 6 years or 5 years.
And if I only 5 years, what happens to
my cost of delay? It becomes so high
that you're better off developing
instantaneously.
If you're in a competitive pharma
business, the optionality starts
dissipate very quickly because you're
always looking over your shoulder.
If you're a monopoly pharma company, you
see the implications, right? You're
going to wait a really long time. You're
not going to get any new new drugs
because nobody's competing against you.
So there is optionality. The optionality
plays out in that additional value over
and above the NPV, but once you bring in
competition, the optionality very
quickly dissipates, but only because I
have that cost of delay. That becomes my
basis for saying you guys can't wait too
long because you don't have 17 years
left, you only 5 years left.
Professor? Yeah.
Even if there's no competition, the
patent starts the patent life starts
from the moment you file the patent, not
when you
develop a commercial
you give up some protection in return
for waiting a little longer, right?
Let's say let's say Glaxo. I I think it
was Glaxo that owned the original the
ulcer drugs where they
they had like 95% of the market. Let's
say you come up with a new ulcer drug.
It's a little better.
Maybe 20% better than the old drug.
Right? You own the market. There's no
competition. Nobody's coming. You know
what? You're going to wait. It's it
sounds morbid. You're waiting because
you're you're you're basically
cannibalizing your own sales
and you give up some years on your new
drug, but you extract more value from
the old drug. So that waiting aspect
will still kick in because and that's
only because you feel there's no
competition. The moment I throw more
competition in, then you're going to see
you you're going to feel the urge I I
can't wait in the next year because I
give up too much.
You know, pharma companies also have
whole teams of lawyers. As you approach
the patent end date, you know what their
job is?
Mith, what do they try to do?
Uh He's going to go work for a pharma
company. He's not going to be one of the
lawyers. He's going to go for an
Novartis uh Novartis blockbuster drug, 2
years left in the patent. The legal
teams will go into play.
They'll try to delay the generic
They'll try to push out. They'll say
they make some modification to the drug
and say add an extra 3 years. You know,
it sounds inhumane and unethical, but if
your entire value as a business rests on
this protection from competition, you're
going to try to extend the life of your
option. That's what they're doing.
So that's
So, that's how you can value a patent.
And it's if it's a company with one or
two blockbuster patents working your way
through the pipeline.
You know what this imply, right? You do
a DCF valuation of that company, you
will undervalue the company.
There is some There's a some optionality
there, but not by very much because if
it's a competitive business, other
people are working on their own drugs.
It still might be okay. So, but if you
have a drug for a for a disease that
only a couple of million people have,
maybe it's a unique enough drug that
nobody else is looking, then you might
end up actually delaying the drug
because of the optionality.
Let's say you have to value a company
which has a patent like Avonex. Biogen
did. But also has some existing drugs
that it's developed already.
You can actually argue that the value of
any pharma company can be written as a
sum of three pieces. One is the value of
existing commercial products that they
have.
Remember, there's no optionality once
you've developed those drugs.
So, there is no optionality for Novo
Nordisk in Wegovy,
you know, or Ozempic because they've
already been developed. So, you take
See, there you can do traditional DCF
valuation.
You add to that the value of any
patents. So, if they're one or two
patents, you value the patents like we
we did Avonex. Being realistic, add the
value of the patents.
So, you take the existing drugs, you add
the patents, and there's a third slice.
Is there an R&D department still work
Yes, and what's the end What's the end
game there? They're trying to develop
new options, right?
Will they create value? Does Novartis'
R&D create value?
You hope so. Right?
And what's the definition of creating
value in in valuation?
That your return on capital is greater
than the cost of capital, that what you
spend on R&D is going to be more than
covered by the patents that will emerge
from the R&D.
So, the third slice
but adds the value that you think the
existing R&D will create in the future.
I'm going to use this with Biogen to
come to value the company. And you can
argue that every pharma company can be
valued as these three slices, but I
wouldn't even try to do this with
Novartis.
Why not?
They have a lot of patents. They have
103 patents. I'll be sitting there
valuing patents from now to eternity,
right? And remember, if you once you
create a portfolio of patents, the
optionality starts to become less of an
issue because then you're looking at a
portfolio of patents rather than an
individual patent.
I would never apply this approach for a
large pharma company.
But for small pharma companies,
especially if Novartis is looking at
acquiring a small pharma company,
there's definitely optionality and it
might be worth thinking about the value
of that small company in these three
slices.
The case of Biogen, it turned out that
they had two commercial products already
out there that licensed.
I think one was to Merck, the other was
to Upjohn.
And these licenses
had had basically Upjohn were paying
them guaranteed fixed amounts every
There are two ways you can license a
drug. One is you can license it for
fixed fees contractually. The other is
you can license for a percentage of the
revenues.
Does it matter?
Yeah.
Why?
Because we have to discount the cash
flow, right?
If I am
My licenses are fixed amounts that Merck
Merck is going to pay me 10 million a
year for the next 10 years. What
discount rate should I use to discount
the 10 million?
Risk free
Is Merck risk free?
But it's guaranteed Okay, so The fact is
the guarantee is only as good as the
guarantor, right? I'd have to use the
cost of debt for Merck as my discount
rate. Think out of the box, right? You
say cost of capital or cost of equity.
This is a case where I'll use the cost
of debt of the guarantor company, not my
cost of debt cuz they're the ones making
the guarantee. If Medicare
had done I'd have used the risk free
rate.
So, I discounted these cash flows back
at the cost of debt of the two
companies. That present value. So, the
cost of debt of 7% as a pre-tax cost of
debt because I'm looking at a pre-tax
revenue from each of those. The present
value I got was 397 million.
Play what if games on that. What if I'd,
you know, licensed the government, I'd
have used the risk free rate. What if I
got a slice of the revenues instead of a
fixed amount? Michael, what would I use
then as my discount rate? I'm trying I
I'm I still got my mind on something you
said earlier, so I'm I wasn't thinking
about that. What do you think, Michael,
if I take
Cost of equity of the Cost of capital if
it's a percent of revenues. Percent of
net income would be cost So, again, go
back to what am I getting a slice off,
and the answer is going to come from it.
Michael, what is on your mind? Yeah, so
whether it's like a royalty deal or a
contractual deal, you're still going to
use the traditional methods to buy.
There's no optionality.
But Yeah, once you develop something,
there's no optionality left anymore,
right? Because basically it's cash flows
discount rate. The discount rate, of
course, has to reflect the kind of
agreement you have. So, that's what
we're discussing right now. It's like
which discount That's why the minute you
develop a patent into a product, the
optionality is done. And that's what
makes you reluctant to pull that last
trigger because once you do it, the drug
is out there with all you know, with its
current structure, and you're you're
kind of stuck with it. That's why there
is this incentive to kind of let's put
it off a few months. Let's put it off a
year. Let's learn more about the drug.
Let's learn about other things it can be
used to treat it on.
The potential upside with a
pharmaceutical drug is limited. Right?
Unless you can take a drug for diabetes
and make it a drug for weight loss at
the time that you do this, which is
unlikely, right? It happens after the
fact.
So, the value for Biogen for its So, now
I have the two pieces of bi Avonex was
their one big patent I valued 907
million.
I valued the the two licensed products
at 397 million. What's left?
Biogen's R&D department. And here I'm
going to just make up stuff. I'll be
quite honest.
Ultimately, the value of R&D comes not
just from the drugs they develop, but
what it cost you to get those drugs,
So, one way to think about this is let's
start by telling you know, let's assume
that Biogen's R&D expense is growing 20%
a year. That's the bad part. That's the
expense part.
But let's say for the next 10 years, I
think this R&D will be a value creating
R&D department. What does that mean? I
invest a dollar in R&D and I get back a
dollar, it's a value neutral R&D
department. If I get more than a dollar,
it's value creating.
I created a dollar 25 in value for every
dollar invested.
It looks made up, you know, where I got
the dollar 25? I took the excess returns
biotech companies make on average.
It's about 3 to 4% more than the cost of
capital. And I said, if I invest a
dollar making 3% more than the cost of
capital, what would work out to? It's
about a dollar 25.
So, think of this as taking the excess
return, return capital versus cost of
capital, and converting into a dollar
value.
At many large pharma companies, that
number is perilously close to one or
below, which means your continuing R&D
is becoming at best value neutral,
and at worst, a value destroying piece
of a company. We talked about in the
context of Merck,
which for the last 15 years has
struggled with its R&D becoming this
drain on value. So, the third piece
actually reduces your value.
Which
in a crude way means that if you fire
entire R&D department today, what's
going to happen to your stock price?
It's going to go up about 15%. That'd be
a good exercise to see what happens when
you get rid of an R&D department when
people have started believing you're
destroying value. And you know what?
Pharma companies have come to that
recognition because many of them are
starting to outsource their R&D.
I mean, I live in San Diego. I'm
surrounded by young biotech and pharma
companies. The end game for them is not
to become businesses. It's to get a drug
far enough in the pipeline that they can
go to Merck and say, "Hey, do you want
to buy this drug in the pipeline?"
You're paying a premium for it, but it's
less than what you would have you'd have
had to pay if you developed it yourself.
So, in this case, basically I'm going to
take the R&D, 120 million, multiply by a
dollar 25, you get the expected value
created that year.
That difference, 30 million dollars, I
discount back. And I use a high cost of
capital because it's a very very
uncertain part of my cash flows. It's
built on R&D continuing to pay off.
And after year 10, I make the assumption
that you're going to become value
neutral.
And that's
being pretty aggressive because most
companies that might happen in three
three four five years. But you can This
becomes a differentiating factor across
pharma companies, right? Some companies
are really good at R&D. This becomes my
mechanism for rewarding companies that I
think are turning out a lot more value
from their R&D.
That value, 380 million, is the value of
my continuing R&D. Yes, it's higher.
Well, you can take the youngest pharma
biotech companies, see what their cost
of capital is. So, I mean, there are
ways I would still get it from public
markets, but I want to kind of treat
those cash flows differently
than my cash flows from existing assets,
and that differently from the drugs that
are working their way through my to my
own pipeline.
So, my sum for the three numbers was
1.622 billion. That's the equivalent of
what you'd have got if you took cash
flows and discounted them back at the
cost of capital in a traditional DCF.
In a traditional DCF, why do I bring in
all this good stuff?
That they have Avonex in the pipeline,
their R&D.
What Ultimately, what are the levers I
have?
Revenue growth,
margins, reinvestment, and dress, right?
So, the way I would have worked this out
if I'm valuing Biogen with the
traditional DCF, I would have given them
higher revenue growth. And then I told
you a story about there's that drug
called Avonex that's in the pipeline,
big blockbuster drug for MS. I'm giving
them a higher revenue growth. I would
have got to the margin and given them
the kinds of margins that companies with
strong blockbuster drugs and patents, 25
30%. Why?
So, in traditional DCF, you try to bring
in through those levers. But what you
will miss is the optionality.
Right?
I don't know how much you leave on the
table by doing it.
But a good DCF of a pharma company would
still leave that option premium over out
of it. Which means that if you find a
pharma company to be roughly fairly
valued using a traditional DCF, I would
pull the trigger.
Buy the company because you add the
optionality, you're probably getting
above that. So, you might never have to
bring in the heavy artillery of a
Black-Scholes model to value the
options. You're just looking at what's
in the pipeline, how big is the market,
and you're saying that's a valuable
enough option that I'm willing
to put a premium on the DCF value.
And that's what one thing I want you to
think about as we go through this. You
look at the Black-Scholes model and say,
"That's really messy. I'm never going to
do it." You might never have to do it.
It's just a mindset that you want to
bring into the process that will change
the way you make decisions.
Let's pass this to a test, Diction.
Isn't $1.25 full of survivorship bias
because you're only looking That's true,
but this is a surviving company, right?
Biogen, by the time I looked at it, was
already publicly traded, had two drugs
out there, their R&D and this was the
third drug. Avonex was the third big
drug they'd come up with. So, you're
drawing on the track record, but the
survivorship bias might be that I'm
looking at companies that that make it
through that.
So, is there any way to account for that
in the model? Well, you'd have to go
back. I mean, you you'd probably have to
look at all But are you going to look at
just If you look at just public
companies, there's no survivorship.
Yeah. But though you started the private
space and you work through, that excess
return very quickly might start to
dissipate because the companies that
don't make it fail and go out of
business.
Let's pass it to the test.
Is there an option here?
Okay, let's work it through. What's your
underlying asset with the patent?
The product, the drug that comes out of
the patent, right? What's the
contingency?
The present value of the cash flows has
to exceed the cost of developing the
drug. So, clearly there is an option.
Is there exclusivity?
Where does it come from?
The patent, but then it's limited
exclusivity because the extent that
there's competition, you You see, the
exclusivity becomes a key test is if
it's a competitive pharma market, it's
exclusive, but
and then you get to the option pricing
part, and you're entering nightmare
territory. What do we say you need for
option pricing models to be easy to
apply? You need the option to be traded,
you need the underlying asset to be
traded, and need to borrow and lend
money at the risk-free rate. Let's take
the third out of the picture, right?
Is the option traded here?
No, the patent, you get Sometimes you
might see transactions. It's not It's
not like I can look up the price on
Bloomberg or what is this patent trading
at? Is the underlying asset traded?
What's your underlying asset here?
That drug that actually gets developed,
it's definitely not traded.
All of the inputs become shakier, right?
I had to make up a standard deviation by
looking at publicly traded companies in
the space. It's not like a call option
on stock.
So, by the time you get to actually
putting a Black-Scholes model, you're
already getting to a hand-waving point.
So, the way this worked out is you gave
me the 907 million, the option, would
you pay this for the I'm not paying the
907 million. I might pay a little bit
more than 547 million,
but there's so many shaky parts in
applying the option pricing model that's
really the mindset you take out of it
rather than the model itself.
So, that's the first I'm going to do a
second real option where we actually
have a shot at applying the option
pricing.
Natural resource company, right?
Look at a natural resource company,
there are two pieces to every natural
resource company. There are developed
reserves from which they do what?
Extract oil, sell the oil, get cash
flows, traditional DCF. And they have
undeveloped reserves where they have the
option to develop the reserves if they
choose to. Key word is they choose to.
So, again, let's set up some structure.
Let's assume the cost of developing
these undeveloped reserves is X.
And the value of the oil under the
ground is V. How do they know how much
value how much oil there is under the
ground?
Well, these geologists knocking on
rocks, 100 million barrels. And let's
face it, their track record is better
than the typical equity research
analyst, so I wouldn't, you know. So,
clearly they were when they told there's
no So, 100 million barrels of oil, you
say if I took it out of the ground, that
becomes the equivalent of V.
If V is greater than X, what will you
do? You'll develop the reserve, make the
difference. If V is less than X,
you wait. For what?
Oil prices to go up, right? I mean, this
is not a question whether oil prices
spike those reserve There is an
optionality. So, if I were to draw this
as a payoff diagram, here's what the
payoff diagram looks like. The cost of
developing the reserve becomes the
strike price.
The underlying asset is the oil under
the ground.
I will develop it the value of the oil
under the ground exceeds the cost of
developing the reserve.
And if that doesn't happen, what did I
spend to get this option?
How did I get these reserves?
Michael.
Lease to the property. One is you either
did exploration costs, now that becomes
like R&D, or you bought the rights to
the reserves. The US government
actually, you know, you auction off the
rights to reserves. So, BP and Exxon go
out and bid, and you win the bid, you
bought the rights. That becomes the
price you pay for the option.
And here, I think we can get much closer
to perfection in terms of being able
able to apply real options. Let's see
what. Let's suppose you wanted to get
the inputs for valuing undeveloped
reserves. Let me Let me emphasize again,
once you develop reserve, the
optionality is pretty much gone.
This is before you develop the reserves.
What is the S in the model? It's the
value of the oil under the ground if you
develop the reserve today. Remember that
with option pricing, the question always
asked is, "What is the value if I
develop today?"
So, you're going to use today's oil
price, forward markets to get expected
oil prices. So, you're doing a
full-fledged capital budgeting, you'll
say 10 million barrels of oil of oil
every year for the next 15 years,
present value of the cash flows. That
becomes the S in the model.
The K becomes the cost of developing the
reserve.
That can vary depending on where the oil
reserves are, right?
If they're in Saudi Arabia, the K might
be a really low number
because the oil is so close to the
surface. If you're in Canada,
you're 5,000 ft under the ground and
frozen. God help you, right? To get to
the oil first, you got to unfreeze the
damn thing. It could cost you hundreds
of millions of dollars. Oil companies
have a pretty good sense
given where the reserves are, what the
cost of developing the reserves are.
Gulf of Mexico, North Sea. So,
basically, I'm sure that ExxonMobil,
they have a table of where the reserves
are, what it costs. That becomes the K
in the model.
Time to expiration becomes a little
messy. If you bought the rights to this
at an auction, it comes with an
expiration date. You don't get it in
perpetuity. You get the right to develop
the reserve anytime over the next 15
years.
If you can't find that, then it becomes
messier because you're going to make a
judgment of how many years do I have
available to get the oil out of the
ground before I lose that right. That
becomes the time to expiration.
What's the the one thing that's causing
the value to change from period to
period?
Oil price. The geologists could change
their mind, but they don't change their
mind that much. It doesn't go from 100
to 10 to 1,000, otherwise you'd fire the
geologists. It's really the oil price
moving. And here we have an advantage.
You see what the advantage is?
When I had to value the patent, what did
I have to do? I had to do a Monte Carlo
simulation or do this, you know, hop,
skip, and jump to figure out what
biotech company Can I figure out what
the standard deviation of oil prices is?
I've been tracking Brent crude prices
all month.
No, I'm not that obsessed. I'm doing it
because I have the equity risk premium,
so I want to see all the numbers every
day each month.
And I can I mean, it's a traded
So, I can go look up the standard
deviation of oil prices. That becomes
the standard deviation model.
Let's say I have a viable reserve.
I'm tempted to wait, right? Why? Because
oil prices could go up.
It's only $65, they could go to 85. Is
there a cost to waiting?
And there are two ways I can frame the
cost. One is the same way I did the
patent, right? 15 years left, how do how
much do I lose? But here's a much more
tangible way of thinking what you lose.
If you develop the reserve today, you
start getting cash flows right away.
By not developing the reserve, you leave
those cash flows under the ground.
That cash flow you give up by not
developing becomes like a dividend
yield.
That cost of delay.
Why do I need that? Because if I don't
have that, you will never develop a
reserve till the very last moment of the
very last day that you have the rights
to. God help you, how much oil can you
get out in 1 minute?
And finally, there's one more practical
issue you face
when you're trying to develop reserves.
An oil company, right? Let's say oil
prices spike to $120 a barrel tomorrow.
I'm not making any predictions, so you
know, this is just a hypothetical.
Exxon Mobil decides to develop all of
its undeveloped reserves.
So, some guy at Exxon Mobil picks up the
phone and says, "Develop the reserves."
Will oil start coming out of the ground
the next day?
No, now you got to get those rigs out
there. And And if you're lucky, maybe 2
years from now the oil will start coming
out of the ground. There are two
problems with that, right? One is
So, is everyone else, every other oil
company? Which it which could affect the
price. So, the 120 could become 60 by
the time it comes out.
The other is there's a time value. Even
if you could lock it in in the forward
market and say, "Look, I can lock in the
price."
You got to wait 2 years to get the cash
flows.
Well, that will do to the option and
make the option less valuable because
you can't instantaneously
exercise the option.
I've got to somehow bring it into the
value and I'm going to try.
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to go back to an acquisition from
way back in time in 1984.
Company called Gulf Oil.
Oil companies became targets for a lot
of hostile acquisitions in the '80s and
Gulf Oil was targeted primarily because
it had lots of undeveloped reserves.
In fact, they had 3,038 million barrels
of oil reserves and the average cost of
developing all these reserves they chose
to develop them all at one go
was about 30.38 billion dollars, 3,038 *
10. So, if they spent 30.38 billion,
they can develop all the reserves.
At the time I did this, the average life
that they had on these reserves was
about 12 years.
These reserves were all over the world,
some for six, some for 14. This is like
a weighted average, 12 years, like the
life of the option.
The price of oil then was $22.38 cents
and the variable cost of getting the oil
out of the ground was $7. So, this is
the actual like direct cost. So, each
barrel of oil they're getting $15.38
cents a barrel.
T-bond rate then was 9%.
Different time, different setting.
And on average, I'm going to assume it
takes about 2 years to develop the
reserves. And if they do develop the
reserves, the cash flows they will get
are going to be about 5% of the value of
the reserves. So, that's the cash flow
they will not have they choose to delay
developing the reserves.
I've got all my ducks in a row. Let's
try to see if we can get the inputs in
option pricing model.
What's my S going to be?
If I develop, it's completely
impractical, right? You try to develop
3.038 billion barrels of oil right away,
you're going to affect the oil price.
Let's ignore that for the moment
and look at the value you get. And I'm
just going to take a shortcut. I'm going
to take the 3.038 billion barrels of oil
multiplied by the $15.38
I make per barrel. Remember, that's the
you know, price minus the variable cost.
And then I'm going to bring it back 2
years. Do you see why I have to like
effectively discount I don't have the
cash flows. So, it looks like
discounting. But what I'm doing is
taking out the cash flows of the first 2
years saying, "There's a development
lag. It'll take me 2 years." What I get
is the value of the oil under the ground
is about 42.38 billion.
That would have been about 44 billion if
I didn't do that 2-year development lag.
So, I'm reducing the value of the op-
option because of the time value.
The value of the oil under the ground is
42.38 billion. It'll cost me 30.38
billion to develop the reserves.
That difference, 12 billion,
is my DCF value for these reserves.
So, if I did a good DCF, that's the
value I'd attach to the reserves.
But you can see what I'm missing, right?
I haven't developed the reserves yet. I
have 12 years left.
The variance in oil price at the time
that I did this was .03.
One thing you have to remember is when
you look at variances, you're looking at
standard deviation squared. Variance
will always look like known low numbers.
Let me give you an example. We have a
company with a standard deviation of
20%. What's its variance?
Go long. 400%, right?
If I did this all in decimal terms, the
standard deviation 20% would become .2.
And you take the square of .2, you get
.04. So, when you look at these
variances, they always look like really
small numbers, but that's because
they're standard deviation they're
squared numbers. So, .04 is really 400%.
.03 is So, .03 is the standard deviation
oil is the variance in oil prices.
The riskless interest rate was 9%. That
was the T-bond rate. And the cost of
delay is that 5% in cash flows I will
not be able to collect
because I'm not developing the reserves.
Let's play it out. D1, D2, and D1 and
Remind me again what N of D2 is?
It's the probability that S will be
greater than K. What's S? The value of
the oil under the ground exceeds. So,
there's a very high chance that I will
exercise this option. No surprise
because you saw the characteristics.
But here's the magic number.
Treated as an option, the value of these
undeveloped reserves is 13.3 billion
dollars. What was the DCF value?
12 billion, right? What What are What's
the extra 1.3 billion? What am I paying
there? Where does the extra 1.3 billion
value come from?
Comes from the fact that oil prices are
volatile.
If oil prices became fixed,
you know what will happen to the option?
It will drop to 12 billion.
The more volatile oil prices become, the
larger the premium you will pay
above your DCF value.
Just this last month, oil prices have
become insanely volatile just like
everything else. You know what that
implies, right? Across the world, oil
companies will become more valuable on
the optionality part, especially you
know, those companies with a lot of
undeveloped reserves because that
variance is going to push up
the value of the optionality.
1980s, oil prices were low and boring.
It's the worst possible combination for
an oil company.
Low prices lower your cash flows. Boring
prices reduce the optionality.
You could hope for at least one of the
two working in your favor if you're an
oil company and it's capturing the
option value.
Let me complete the Gulf Oil valuation.
I valued their developed reserves. They
had actual reserves that they would that
that they developed already on which
they were making 915 million dollars in
cash flows on average.
They had about 12 years of those
reserves left. Take the present value of
the 915 million at a cost So, this is
like a traditional DCF valuation. Using
12.5% cost of capital, I get a value for
the developed reserves of 5.065 billion.
Gulf Oil is a company
gets about 5 billion of its value from
developed reserves, 13.3 billion from
its undeveloped reserves.
If I did this for Exxon Mobil or Royal
Dutch, what do you think the breakdown
is going to be between developed and
undeve- developed reserves?
Where is the most of the value going to
come from?
Mature oil companies, most of the value
will come from developed reserves.
If I take a Petrobras,
much of the value comes from undeveloped
reserves because they have really a lot
of high-cost reserves
that it takes a really high oil price.
So, you can all see already see, compare
across oil companies, not all oil
companies are built the same from a
value perspective.
Cuz they're designed to get their
benefits either from higher oil prices
with a lot of developed reserves or
higher variance if you have a lot of
undeveloped reserves.
I'm sure Petrobras
has been better positioned because of
oil prices becoming more volatile over
the last month because so much of its
value comes from undeveloped reserves.
You want volatility as your ally.
So, the value that I got here, if I
added up those, you get the value of the
firm. Again, I could have done a
traditional DCF value, right?
Expected cash flows. The undeveloped
reserves would then have shown up as
higher growth rates because they can
develop the reserves, but I'd still have
missed the optionality if I did this.
So, bringing in that option perspective
gives you that that that that change in
mindset.
Let's talk about the option to expand.
This is the option that really excites
real option people because it allows
gives you the license to really stupid
things
and claim it's because there's
optionality. So, let's set up the
process. Here's how the option to expand
goes about. There are two projects.
The first project is a traditional
project, but it has a negative net
present. It's a bad project.
Why are you taking it? Cuz it gives you
the rights to a second project, which is
an even worse project.
This is absurd. Why would I take a bad
project to get rights to an even worse
project? The second project is really
big and there's a lot of uncertainty
about it. Now, do you see why this is so
attractive to strategic thinkers and
consultants? They can advise you to do
stupid things. And the less they know
about the future, the more they can push
you to do these stupid things because
there is this big things waiting for you
in the future that they have no idea
what they are.
So, again, let's think of it in terms of
an option.
It's that second project where the
option comes about, the expansion
option. And here's what the inputs are
going to look like.
The present value of the cash flows from
that expansion will become the
equivalent of the stock price. The cost
of expansion will become the strike
price.
So, the present value of the cash flows
from expansion exceed the cost, you will
expand. What if that never happens?
What do you lose?
What did you have to do to get to the
second project?
You had to take that first project. And
what did I say about the first project?
It has a negative net present value. You
write it off saying, "I wish we never
invested in AI."
It's I mean, if you think about it,
space is like AI.
The reason companies are spending
immense amounts, it's not because
they're stupid enough to think the end
maybe of what they're doing today is
positive, but because they think there
might be expansion options out there,
which are potentially so valuable if
they pay off, that they cover the cost
of the bad net present value seen in the
initial investment.
So, let's start to develop a structure
of thinking about it, because I think
you will run into a lot of this real
options argument at work wherever you
decide to work.
Suppose I came to you with a company.
Make it a, you know, uh it's it's a
computer it's a computer software
company, privacy company, that produces
software.
I take the present value of the cash
flows, do a traditional DCF, and I come
up with a value of 115 million.
So, revenue growth, margins,
reinvestment. I use the FCF of Ginzburg
model, 115 million.
And then I say, "By the way, this
company is going to accumulate a
database, because remember they have
customers who come to them with security
problems, and they help them. And they
the customers also have to give you
access to their to to their data." So,
you're going to accumulating a database
that you think you can convert into a
viable business by itself
anytime over the next 5 years.
So, I ask you to work through the cash
flows on this, and you say, "Well, the
business is expected to create So, this
is the I'm talking about the second
business. It's supposed to it will
generate about $40 million in cash flows
every year, and after-tax cash flows,
and the cost of capital is 12%."
But the cost of entering the business is
a half a billion dollars.
Already you can see, even before you do
a present value, that this doesn't look
good, right? Even without discounting,
40 * 10 is 400 million. That's less than
the 500 million. Once I start
discounting, it's going to get even
worse.
But you haven't made that investment.
It's in the future.
Let's value it as an option. You're
going to see the magic of real options,
and how it lets you do things that you
otherwise wouldn't be able to get away
with.
Huge amount of standard deviation. Why?
It's a very uncertain business.
And the risk-free rate is 3%. So, I plug
in the numbers. The present value of 40
million for 10 years at 12% is 226
million.
What I have to do to enter the business
is 500 million. If I stop right there,
that's an NPV of minus 274 million,
right?
But because I'm so uncertain about the
business, if I compute the value of the
option, the value that I get for the
option is 56 million.
A project with a negative net present
value of minus 227 million, an
incredibly risky business, the
optionality there
is such that it's worth 56 million.
You're getting that option on top of
your DCF.
So, many of you value companies where
you say, "But they could do something
with this platform." You're basically
making an argument for optionality.
And if it's a business with this huge
amount of uncertainty about the future,
there's a basis for it.
I mean, we're stretching the limits of
option pricing models here in terms of
how we're getting the inputs,
but you can't argue with the fact that
sometimes in uncertain businesses
that expansion option, even though it's
not viable today, could add a
significant amount of value
to the company.
Yes.
Let's say I'm um I am the company, I'm
producing my 10-K. Yeah. So, you're
already telling me that instead of
saying that, "Hey, I'm doing this
expansion." It's just saying You're not
doing it, right? Because right now it's
not viable, right?
And if I simply say that, "Hey, we could
be doing this simply. I just have like
million dollars of additional
You got to convince investors that that
you can pull it off, right? And that's
And companies do this all the time. You
look at prospectuses for young
companies. What do they tell you about
the potential total addressable market
is 10 billion, 100 billion. The case of
Uber, 5.2 trillion. Why are you throwing
it in there?
It's for that options argument. We
haven't figured out how to do this yet,
but this is a really big business,
right? They don't even have to give you
specifics, and you're falling for the
optionality. Would you say an
optionality always always always has a
positive NPV?
It does, but how much will depend on
exclusivity. You know the question I
would ask them here is, "What's so
unique about your database?"
If it's just, "I have names of clients
and their phone numbers." Okay, that's
not going to give you 56 million dollars
of value. It's because you've collected
unique data about your clients that you
and only you have. And that's why the
exclusivity question becomes Cuz you can
already see the dangers of opening this
door, right? People say, "Pay me a
premium. I have a big platform.
Pay me a premium. I have a database."
And the question I'm asking is, "How
unique or exclusive is your database?"
The more unique it is,
the more value there is to that option.
So, one way to frame this is to think
about the fact that I've connected two
investments. I made you take that bad
first investment, because I said, "If
you don't do that, you can't take the
second investment."
So, the first question you got to ask
is, "Do I have to do that?"
Can I just collect the information some
other way to make that second
investment? Why do I have to do the
first? So, I'm going to convince you to
do the first one. And the second thing
I've got to convince you is that there's
some kind of uniqueness here,
exclusivity. That's why licenses and
patents are an obvious So, if I do this
first bad investment, if I get a license
to do something for the next 10 years,
there's clearly much more optionality
than an opportunity to do something over
the next 10 years.
The danger here is you could do all the
dirty work of collecting information in
that first project,
but your competitors are watching you
while you collect the information,
and just as you get ready to launch the
expansion,
they beat you to the punch. It's great
to have other your competitors do all
the dirty work, spend the money.
Now, the example I give in my corporate
finance class is a Marriott goes out and
opens 10 hotels in China. Why? It's a
big market.
Expansion option, right?
So, they look at how the hotels do. If
they do really well, they plan to open
100 more hotels.
The flaw there is
there probably are people in Hilton who
are just checking in as guests to see
how full your hotel is.
So, you're doing really well, Hilton is
collecting the information, and just as
you get ready to launch your 100 more
hotels, Hilton beats you to the punch.
You got to show me there's some
exclusivity before I start attaching
that option value.
So, let's uh pass expansion option to
the test. Is there an underlying asset?
Yes, that expansion project. What's the
contingency? If the present value of the
cash flows from expanding exceed the
expansion cost, you will expand. If not,
you will not do it.
Is there exclusivity? It depends.
This is one option case where you have
to make that You you got to do the dirty
work of saying, "Is there enough
exclusivity there? Do you have a
license? Do you have protection against
competition?" Or is there something that
you think is just a big market? With AI,
this is going to be the question you
need to ask companies that claim that
they're going to enter the AI space
because it's a big market.
What is it that you're bringing that is
exclusive that will create that
optionality? And if there is, then I'm
willing to listen, because it
potentially could be a valuable option.
Can I apply an option pricing model?
Only if I hold my nose, cover my ears,
and essentially hope to see nothing bad,
right? Let's take the inputs.
Is the option traded here?
No, it's a project. It's a right to take
a project, right? It's not traded. The
underlying asset is the cash flows from
the project, not traded.
I'm effectively jumping into the deep
end of the pool with nothing holding me
up. I'm really stretching the limits of
option pricing. Here again, I would say
it's a mindset that you need to bring,
and the question you ask about
exclusivity, rather than actually
getting a number, that will separate.
Third and final option. What is that
popping over there? Is there somebody
back behind there? I don't know. I hope
not.
Talk about the option to abandon.
This is the only real option you're
going to run into that's a put option.
Almost everything in real options is a
call option. Why is it a put option? The
option to abandon basically gives you
the right to walk away from an
investment if it's not working out.
Collect some money, maybe.
But you protect yourself against
continuing to have negative cash flows.
So, I'd draw it as a payoff diagram.
What you get from abandoning becomes a
strike price. If the present value of
the cash flows from continuing falls
below the abandonment value, you
abandon.
If not,
what do you pay? You pay the price for
getting that abandonment option. You had
They you had to give up something up
front for that flexibility. You got to
make sure that that's That amount is the
price of your option.
So, I'll end with an example. Let's
assume
that you're Lear Aircraft. Lear makes
these tiny executive jets,
and I'm Airbus.
And you want to enter the commercial
aircraft market.
So, you approach me
because you want to do a joint venture.
So, in the joint venture, you're going
to have 50%, I'm going to have 50%. You
have to pay half a billion, I'll have to
pay half a billion.
So, as Airbus, I ask you, "What are my
cash flows going to look like?" You work
through the cash flows, and you tell me
that the present value of my cash flows
This going to be 480 million.
Already you're getting Yeah. Now, how
much do you have to invest? 500 million.
I'm telling you the present value can
So, you tell me, "No, I'm not
We're not doing it."
But, let's say you really, really want
me as your partner.
So, you offer me a sweetener deal. And
here's what the sweetener deal is.
Anytime
over the next 5 years This is a 30-year
project. If I change my mind,
you'll buy back my 50% share
at 400 million.
Lower than the 5 million that I
invested, but what have I done? I've
essentially limited your downside to 100
million.
And if you feel this is a really
horrible project, you can walk away.
I've given you an abandonment option.
You got the option for the next 5 years.
The S right now is is 480 million. The K
is 400 million. It's out of the money.
Remember, it's a put option.
What are you going to watch for?
Why did I give you the rights offer only
the first 5 years not for the next 30?
If I gave you this right for the next 30
years, what are you going to do?
Suck up all the cash flow for the next
29 years and 363 days. 2 days before the
end of the person, "Look, I'd like my
480 million now."
So, it's got to end well before the
project ends. Otherwise, I'm digging a
hole for myself.
Let's say I did a simulation of the cash
flows and I came up with a variance of
0.16. A lot of uncertainty in this
business. And
I did my option pricing. Here's what the
options would look like. The S is the
480 million. That's the present value of
the cash flows today. The K becomes a
400 million you can get if you walk
away. So, it's in it's an
out-of-the-money option as a put option.
0.16 is the variance. You got 5 years
to make this decision. And each year you
wait, remember there's one less year of
cash flows.
So, there's going to be a decline in
value each year.
Riskless rate is 8%. Oh, sorry, 6%.
Here's what the put option
comes back with.
The value of this option to abandon
is 73.23 million. What was the net
present value you had before we did
this? -20 million, right? By giving you
this option to walk away,
I've effectively converted a negative
net present value project into a
positive net present value project.
The only problem is that 73.23 million
comes out of my side of value.
So, if I'm Lear giving away this option,
I better be creating a net present value
well above it.
Because if I don't, I'm going to end up
with a negative NPV at the end of this
process.
The right to be able to walk away from
your mistakes is a can add incredible
personal life, business life. You make a
choice, right?
It's good to have it. That's basically
what you're seeing play out here.
Especially with long-term projects and
infrastructure investments, it's good to
have that right.
So, in terms of implications for
investment analysis, it basically means
flexibility is a good thing. We talk
about some companies being flexible and
adaptable.
I'd use an option pricing argument. For
the longest time, Goldman Sachs's
reputation as an investment bank rested
in the fact
that they almost always seem to jump on
to big markets ahead of everybody else
and jump out of bad markets ahead of
everybody else. Maybe having an ex-CEO
as the Secretary of the Treasury might
have helped.
But, but that That was their reputation
is they somehow managed to avoid those
big losses. I mean, that reputation's
been dented and dinged over the last
decade or so.
But, some companies are more flexible,
more adaptable than other companies. And
to me, that is really an abandonment
option, a put option that these
companies have that gives them that
extra value.
So, I will see you on Monday and um you
know, we'll talk about the last the last
aspect of of the option, which is you
know, distressed equity as an option.
That's the only option you can try on
your company because neither of the
options we talked about now can actually
be explicit
value.
Have you done yet? No.
How long have you looked at it? Stating
you guys know
Take care, everybody.
Yes?
Okay.
What I've done was English I thought